con precisión británica a las 14:22 de
la tarde inicio la operación Lion
[Música]
el ataúd con los restos de la monarca
salió del Palacio de buckingham la
marcha fúnebre avanzó junto a la escolta
militar el Rey Carlos III sus hermanos y
sus hijos William y Harry
[Música]
fue un recorrido marcado por la
solemnidad más de 38 minutos en los que
el sonido de las almas de cañón
y el Big Bang
retumbaron en honor a la monarca la
procesión fue acompañada por miles de
ciudadanos que querían vivir en primera
persona este momento histórico
mucho poder despedirme de ella
ver a sus nietos verla fue algo que
nunca olvidaré nunca lo olvidaré
Acabo de ver el fallecimiento de la
reina literalmente ante mis ojos y están
triste tan profundo cumplir mi lealtad
hacia ella cuando estuve en la fuerza
aérea durante 22 años Así que es muy
triste
a su llegada a la sede del parlamento se
instaló una guardia de honor previa a
una ceremonia en el Westminster Hall el
sitio permanecerá abierto al público
durante cuatro días en los que se espera
que unas 700.000 personas le den el
último adiós
el féretro permanecer allí hasta el
próximo 19 de septiembre cuando se
realizará el funeral de estado de Isabel
II